ja und auch die korona maßnahmen der
korona maßnahmen wahnsinn nimmt einfach
kein ende heute der hamburg hammer die
hansestadt die mit der zweitniedrigsten
instituts deutschlands will sich
mittwoch zum hotspot erklären so würden
dann eben die masken pflicht und auch 2g
und 3g bestehen bleiben gleichzeitig
verhandeln die gesundheitsminister
mehrere bundesländer über einen antrag
der bund soll sein
infektionsschutzgesetz verschärfen
lassen pflicht bis anfang mai hotspot
regionen sollen dann auch bundesweit
gelten doch der wird heute direkt wieder
abgelehnt für
einige länder haben einen antrag
gestellt dass das infektionsschutzgesetz
noch einmal angefasst wird diese anträge
sind abgelehnt worden es wird kann es
gibt keine rechtliche grundlage für
nationale regeln mehr wenn es keine
nationale überlastung ergibt aber ich
habe ja noch mal ausdrücklich
aufgefordert die hotspot regelung auch
zu nutzen sowie das hamburg und
mecklenburg vorpommern jetzt machen
werden
ja und was bleibt wie schon so oft in
der korona krise ist es einfach nur
verwirrend es scheint als wären die
gesundheitsminister mit den eigenen
maßnahmen nicht zufrieden und wetzen
irgendwie alles auf den bund ab der hält
wiederum dagegen und darüber möchte ich
jetzt einmal sprechen bei mir im studio
ist bild chefin bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer jan wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter ja wir haben das gerade schon
gehört auch von karl lauterbach und dem
beitrag ja auch gesehen hamburg will
sich nach mecklenburg vorpommern als
zweites bundesland zum hotspot erklären
lassen das bedeutet dass maßnahmen
beispielsweise wie eine zweig regelung
oder auch masken pflicht beim einkaufen
dann nochmal weiter mindestens vier
wochen gelten also mindestens dann
steigt das duell eigentlich steigt da
irgendjemand noch durch deswegen ist es
gut täglich auf bild.de zu gehen auf
bild tv oder dann auch die bild zeitung
zu lesen weil wir darüber berichten nein
es ist in der tat jetzt wahnsinnig
schwer dadurch zu steigen und
interessant ist das was karl lauterbach
ja auch sagt es gab einige bundesländer
unter anderem baden württemberg die
heute einen entsprechenden antrag
gestellt haben dass man also die masken
fliegt er noch deutlich länger ausweiten
kann oder der bahn der maske nicht
festhalten kann dieser antrag
abgeschmettert worden
und was jetzt sehr interessant ist wie
karl lauterbach ja dieses diese masken
pflicht bzw
das auslegt was die bundesländer künftig
machen können da gibt's einen echten
krach in der ampelkoalition nämlich mit
dem bundesjustizminister karl lauterbach
sagt ja die ganzen bundesländer können
sich zum hotspot erklären hat ja heute
noch mal richtig dafür geworben dass sie
das auch tun und der
bundesjustizminister mit dem ich vorhin
kurz sprechen konnte sagt genau das
gegenteil der sagt nämlich uns dass das
nicht möglich ist sondern dass es
eigentlich wenn auch nur regional
begrenzt ist dass man diese hotspot
regelung anwendet das bedeutet dann dass
man angeschmissen corona einschränkungen
wie beispielsweise der 3g regelung
festhalten kann also da ein echter
kracht zwischen karl lauterbach und
marco buschmann eigentlich sollten ja
jetzt ende märz anfang april jegliche
massnahmen verfallen jegliche corona
maßnahmen obwohl eben die instanzen
relativ hoch sind wie ist deine
einschätzung warum wird es jetzt wieder
so verwirrend warum komplett wieder so
ein wirrwarr auf uns zu ja einige
bundesländer sagen wir wollen uns zum
hotspot erklären und andere wie es
beispielsweise bayern heute gemacht hat
sagen wir wollen es nicht da gab es
druck von der fdp die hat man klage
gedroht und ministerpräsident markus
söder hat jetzt klargestellt da in
bayern wird insgesamt kein hotspot
obwohl man das gerade bei markus söder
ja eigentlich erwartet hätte aus den
vergangenen wochen und monaten was man
zumindest von ihm gehört hat ja
interessant ist auch dass wir zum
beispiel ein bundesland haben sprich
nehmen an den knopf jetzt einfach gewerk
spanien das hat heute corona so als als
ganz normale krankheit eigentlich
eingestuft also als eine krankheit die
wir eine grippe behandelt wird das heißt
wenn man in ancona er krank in spanien
und keine großen symptome hat dann gilt
ab heute eigentlich folgendes dass man
sein normales leben mehr oder weniger
weiterführen kann also nicht in
quarantäne muss oder in isolation und
wenn man dann den schnitt macht und
jetzt nach deutschland kommt und sagt ja
wir haben ja weitere hotspot regelungen
beispielsweise in hamburg vier wochen
länger in mecklenburg vorpommern und
möglicherweise auch zum beispiel in
baden württemberg dann sieht man doch
mit wieviel unterschiedlichen
messeinheiten dass wir mindestens mit
zweierlei maß in europa gemessen wird
hat so mittlerweile wirklich immer noch
das gefühl dass eben die politikerinnen
und politiker endlich gar nicht so
richtig wissen wie sie eben mit coronels
umgehen sollen was glaubst du denn wie
lange wird es noch dauern bis wir quasi
spanien nach folgen mit eben dieser
einordnung der krankheit dass wir eben
nicht mehr in quarantäne müssen weil
eben schon viele menschen geimpft sind
viele menschen jetzt auch schon erkrankt
waren wann wann sie ihn wieder nach was
wir eigentlich lange machen wollten das
klingt jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig
aber ich glaube das hängt auch damit ab
wie populär ein ministerpräsident in
seinem bundesland ist wir wissen bei
markus söder dass er massiv unter druck
ist und dass viele viele bayern mit
seinem kurs in der korona pandemie alles
andere als zufrieden waren und wir
wissen beispielsweise auch dass der
ministerpräsident von schleswig-holstein
da ein günther vorwahl entsteht der war
bisher auch er immer auf der bremse aber
da sie zb holstein mittlerweile auch
anders aus ich glaube nicht dass
beispielsweise schleswig-holstein sich
zum hotspot erklären wird also man darf
da bei dieser ganzen entwicklung die
innenpolitische lage in einem bundesland
nicht außer acht lassen peter
tschentscher in hamburg beispielsweise
der hat noch ein bisschen zeit bis
wieder einmal ist und wir wissen auch
von manu schwesig aus mecklenburg
vorpommern dort wird es noch weitere
vier jahre dauern bis überhaupt wieder
eine wahl im nordosten stattfindet die
ist erst wiedergewählt worden von daher
gibt es da aus ihrer sicht erst mal kein
handlungsbedarf ich glaube das muss man
immer sehen was steht an wahlen an wie
populär ist gerade ein ministerpräsident
mit den maßnahmen die er bisher
durchgeführt hat und deswegen wird es
einen flickenteppich in deutschland
geben gab es denn jetzt schon reaktionen
aus der politik eben auf die
beziehungsweise auf die aufhebung der
maßnahmen in spanien haben sich der
politikerin und kritiker schon zu
geäußert dass sie sagen genau so hätte
ich das auch gerne oder eben geht gar
nicht also die fdp ist ja seit monaten
diejenige partei die darauf dringt dass
viele viele maßnahmen auslaufen und dass
die länder die hoheit eigentlich
bekommen und darüber entscheiden können
und jemand wir hören aus der fdp dass
man mit dem was in spanien passiert
eigentlich sehr zufrieden dass einige
politiker sagen hinter vorgehaltener das
könnten sie sich auch gut für
deutschland vorstellen wir wissen auch
beispielsweise dass über diese
quarantäne
pflicht eine verringerung der quarantäne
pflichten hier bei uns ja auch
debattiert wird sowohl in der fdp in der
ampelkoalition der kassenärzte chef
andreas gassen hat ende letzter woche
gesagt es wäre gut wenn wir bei der
quarantäne auch zu anderen regelungen
kommen würden beispielsweise personen
die gar keine symptome haben dass die
gar nicht mehr in quarantäne müssten
sondern einfach mit masken schutz aber
weiter dann auch beispielsweise normal
am arbeitsplatz arbeiten könnten weil er
einfach sagt es gibt halt jetzt so viele
viele infizierte aber wenn sie keine
symptome haben dann können wir sie gar
nicht mehr zu hause einsperren sonst
würde würden einfach viel zu viele
menschen fehlen und ja das ist die
debatte die wir hier bei uns sehen und
spanien setzt das um ist also würde ich
mal sagen wirklich ein zwei drei vier
fünf wochen weiter als wir sind frage
unser gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der ja gestern auch noch hier
war und auch noch mal gesagt hat er sei
eigentlich gar keine angst mache wir
haben ihn ja sehr oft angstmacher
genannt eben vor allen dingen weil er
immer das ganz negative gesehen hat
immer den schlimmsten verlauf gesehen
hat was würdest du sagen es ist jetzt
eine richtige klatsche wieder für ihn
das ist keine klatsche das ist eher ein
machtkampf innerhalb der ampel wie
gerade schon besprochen dass ein gesetz
und es gibt zwei minister nämlich karl
lauterbach auf der einen seite und den
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann auf
der anderen seite wäre eines von der spd
marco buschmann von der fdp die sich
jetzt um die auslegung eines gesetzes
streiten und der der spd minister gerne
an maßnahmen festhalten würde der
versucht das gesetz auch entsprechend
auszulegen ja also die bundesländer
ergreift das ruhig ich würde euch so
helfen dass ihr diese maßnahmen weiter
weiter umsetzen könnt und es gibt dann
den minister von der fdp da sagte mein
freund so haben wir nicht gewettet wir
wollen das gerne anders machen wir haben
von einem freiheitstag gesprochen und
wir wollen wenn überhaupt dass maßnahmen
nur ganz ganz begrenzt funktionieren und
hat auch gesagt hör zu uns ja das werde
im zweifel dann die gerichte entscheiden
müssen wir werden uns also auch auf
viele gerichtsprozesse wieder einstellen
dürfen vielen dank jan schäfer an die
ausführungen für die ausführung über die
aktuellen jako maßnahmen da wenn wir
natürlich dran bleiben und alle
informationen werden sie natürlich immer
hierbei bild tv bekommen oder auch
daneben auf bild.de